you mentioned that the young physicists
that um you talk to or whose work you
follow
have quite a lot of fun breaking with
the traditions of the past the
assumptions of the past what advice
would you give to young people today in
high school and college not just
physicists but
in general how to have a career they can
be proud of how they can have a life
they can be proud of how to make their
way in the world from the lessons
from the wins and the losses in your own
life what what what little insights
could you pull out
i would say
the universe is lot more interesting
than you might expect
and you
are a lot more special and interesting
than you might expect you might think
that you're just a little
tiny
irrelevant
100 pound 200 pound
person in a vast billions of light years
across space
and that's not the case
you are in some sense the being that's
creating that space all the time every
time you look
so
waking up to who you really are
outside of space and time
as the author of space and time is the
author of everything that you see
the author of space and time
sorry you're the author of space and
time right and i'm the author of space
and time and space and time is just one
little data structure many other
consciousnesses are creating other other
data structures they're authors of
various other things so so realizing and
then realizing that that
i had this feeling that growing up and
going and called
reading all these textbooks oh man it's
all been done
yeah
if i'd just been there you know 50 years
ago i could have discovered this stuff
but that's all in the textbooks now
well
believe me the textbooks are going to
look silly in 50 years
and it's your chan your chance to write
the new textbook so so
of course study the current textbooks
you have to understand them you there's
no way to progress until you understand
what's been done but but then
the only limit is your imagination
frankly
you